now police in this country are under
attack cities have become war zones at
least 2 000
cops have been assaulted lit on fire
with molotov cocktails hit with sticks
pelted with bricks rocks frozen water
bottles they've been stabbed they've
been shot they've been run over
so far this year 45 police officers have
been murdered in the line of duty 33
shot nine were victims of vehicular
assault
and one was beaten to death all told
eight were the victims of an
ambush like this attempted assassination
for months
democrats well they've done nothing but
pretty much fanned the flames of this
destructive rage and even denied it's
happening
we have been warning liberal democrats
this rhetoric is incendiary it is
dangerous it would not end well the dnc
convention they barely mentioned the
violence that telling us
didn't happen instead democrats across
the country
are joining arm and arm with the effort
to defund the police department
we've told you that wouldn't end well
they passed laws preventing local
officers from using
nonviolent tactics to disperse crowds
you know like tear gas and pepper spray
they ordered law enforcement to stand
down as buildings were being torched and
vandalized and even police
precincts taken over they even joined
the so-called protests
that dehumanize and vilify police and
meanwhile biden said police
oh they become the enemy and he would
absolutely redirect funds away from law
enforcement
kamala harris are you proud of yourself
tonight because you cheered
the idiotic mayor of los angeles when
mayor garcetti cut 150 million dollars
from the police budget there
even promoted that fund to help bail out
violent anti-police rioters out of jail
and by the way kamala and joe look at
their manifesto
they want to go to this no bail madness
that they have in new york
mayor garcetti compared police to
killers ocasio-cortez
called for all police funding to be
stripped
congresswoman o'mar called for the
police everywhere to be dismantled and
that's not all
here's some of the worst rhetoric from
top democrats
they have some answering after all of
this today
surplus military equipment for law
enforcement they don't need that
the last thing you need is an up armored
humvee coming into a neighborhood it's
like the military invading
they don't know anybody they become the
enemy they're supposed to protecting
these people
so my generic point is that do we agree
that we can redirect some of the funding
yes uh absolutely when we dismantle it
we get rid of that cancer we have
confused
the the idea that to achieve safety
you put more cops on the street the
rhetoric is unacceptable
this is a war on police and frankly a
war on innocent people and towns and
cities across the country
this rhetoric needs to stop those that
use it need to be held accountable keep
in mind
there were no supportive comments for
police from
any top democrats for months only when
it showed up in the polls that they
decide oh maybe we'll talk about it
for years by the way when police were
vilified dehumanized
you know you'd be hard-pressed to find a
civil single democrat
defending the police remember this
make it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way that's blm but tonight not
only are police facing constant
demonization from the left they're now
also facing a wave of violent crime and
almost
all of america's democrat democratic-run
cities and states run by them for
decades
for eight long years biden obama they
did
and said nothing four thousand homicides
when they were president and vice
president in
obama's hometown of chicago twenty
thousand
shooting they barely mentioned it they
didn't lift a finger
to help the people in chicago biden is
running mate proposing a set of plans
that would
only make the violence worse worse here
with